This friday experience the two-episode
premiere only on disney plus leave us alone ben
it's my responsibility the boy must
be trained like you trained his father
they're coming
stay hidden the key to hunting jedi is patience
obi-wan kenobi streaming may 27 on disney plus
Welcome back everyone this is my new obi wan
kenobi trailer video we have episodes coming
in a couple days so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get everything
i will be doing videos for all the episodes
i have a bunch of bonus videos planned and
there's a whole bunch of stuff they're going
to be doing during this part of the timeline
there's a bunch of new footage i know there's
a bunch of questions about what's going on with
the canon what they're doing with obi-wan kenobi
and darth vader's rematch there's supposed to be
a couple different rematches during this series
like there won't just be one fight between darth
vader and obi-wan kenobi there'll be a couple
different fights and i know there's a lot of
questions about how they're going to work the
timeline out because they have the idea of
young luke skywalker you have the inquisitors
coming to tatooine how is it that the emperor
that darth vader stopped looking at tatooine as a
place of interest what does obi-wan kenobi do to
prevent them from coming back to tatooine just
right after the events of the series to keep
looking there the other brand new character that i
haven't talked about in previous videos is kumail
nanjiani's character because you see like a brief
shot of him in some of the earlier trailers and a
little more new footage of this brand new planet
daiyu which is kind of like space hong kong the
way they talk about it they say that only a little
bit of the series takes place on tatooine that's
probably at the beginning of the series and then
obi-wan kenobi is eventually forced to leave there
whoever gets into trouble that he winds up
trying to save kamel nanjiani says that he's
supposed to play a scoundrel during the series on
the streets of daiu who winds up in the middle of
all the trouble between obi-wan kenobi and the
inquisitors darth vader and the emperor he has
to make this choice about who he wants to help
or whether he wants to sell obi-wan kenobi out
there were a few questions about whether
or not he was going to be playing a force
sensitive because he's a much older
adult and usually you didn't train
older adults like that at least this
part of the timeline he is too old
too old to begin the training the robes that he
was wearing made him seem like he could have been
a jedi character but it sounds like the way he
talks about him he might just be a scoundrel
so at least the way he talks about him he's
more of a han solo type like a con man with the
heart of gold who winds up helping obi-wan kenobi
eventually but basically what's going on in this
part of the timeline is that darth vader's castle
has already been constructed on mustafar one of
the reasons why he chose to put it on mustafar is
because the emperor pushed him to do that because
just in general the planet the system was powerful
in the dark side of the force but because so much
of his power and his connection to the dark side
of the force was tied to his anger the emperor
wanted to make him as angry as possible as often
as possible that's why the emperor encouraged him
to spend as much time as possible in the place of
his greatest failure as he saw it and even though
he probably hated sand more than he hated being on
mustafar tatooine itself was not powerful in the
dark side of the force the way that mustafar
was if you read a lot of the star wars comic
books they kind of explored this idea too the sith
architect that he got to build the actual castle
used designs meant to harness the ley lines in
the dark side of the force so that it was even
more powerful in the dark side he actually built
the castle to specifications that would help
him use the dark side of the force to try and
penetrate this barrier between life and death
so that he could find a way to bring padme back
from actual death there's a brief moment in the
comics where he comes close to that like he
is able to open a window but he isn't actually
able to bring padme back from death and if it
wasn't clear the fortress inquisitorius where
all the inquisitors do all their training their
special castle it's also a major location that
you go to during the jedi fall and order game
that's on one of the other moons of mustafar
so while darth vader is busy stewing in his
castle over here on mustafar the inquisitors
are really close by even though technically
he really didn't care about them that much he
really only cared about finding obi-wan kenobi and
killing him at least at this part of the timeline
and then getting rid of all the rest of the force
sensitives because he didn't want the emperor
finding another really powerful force-sensitive
person training them and then replacing him
quote unquote the way that he replaced count
dooku the emperor's last apprentice do it
that also gets into the whole storyline with
the jedi librarian and the holocron with the
identities of all the force sensitive from the
jedi temple and what happened to grogu after order
66. i'll talk about that in a second too because
all that stuff is happening in the background
during this part of the timeline when darth vader
and the inquisitors are going around trying to
hunt down all these force sensitives and the jedi
survivors of order 66. i've already talked about
obi-wan kenobi and darth vader having a couple
different run-ins during the actual series like
they won't just meet each other and fight again
once but the whole idea is that when the series
picks up obi-wan kenobi does not know that anakin
skywalker is still alive he thinks that he died on
mustafar but darth vader anakin skywalker does
know about obi-wan kenobi and he really really
wants to find him we'll see what his first words
are when he actually sees him again in person
i just think the idea is that when obi-wan kenobi
eventually is confronted with anakin skywalker
darth vader he's going to be this big wtf moment
like what you're still alive because during all
the trailers especially during the first couple of
episodes nobody actually says the name darth vader
or anakin skywalker or talks about what happened
on mustafar one of the brand new inquisitors reva
she's actually a brand new character that hasn't
appeared in the canon before she says he'll find
you you can't run from him but she doesn't say i'm
talking about darth vader she just says him and
just answer all the questions about darth vader
not going after luke skywalker before this because
he'd been using the name luke skywalker remember
he's only about 10 years old when the series picks
up so for the most part it sounds like owen and
baru lars have been keeping him relatively close
to their moisture farm and he hasn't been running
around telling everybody they can listen what his
entire name is so at least at this part of the
timeline when he's still really young the secret
is still relatively self-contained but eventually
i think the idea is that when he does get older
he becomes a teenager he starts flying around in
his t16 bullseye womp rats which they featured
during the book of boba fett that was beggar's
canyon that mando was flying around in in the
repurposed naboo starfighter just like the one
the anakin skywalker himself had flown in during
phantom menace a lot of phantom menace a lot of
prequel easter eggs during the mandalorian series
and during the book of boba fett wizard this is so
wizarding but i think the major reason why darth
vader the emperor the other inquisitors who were
still alive the other imperials didn't just turn
right back around and come back to tatooine
like wait a minute somebody is using the name
skywalker this seems like we should check this out
is probably because he doesn't fully learn about
the identity of luke skywalker that he is his
son that his children survive because he thinks
that both of his children and his wife padme died
so during the series they prevent the inquisitors
from learning about luke skywalker's identity they
prevent them from learning about leia as well and
if the imperial security bureau had heard any talk
in this part of the system this part of the outer
rim of a skywalker name being used they probably
wouldn't have paid it too much mine because
within the empire it was not common knowledge
that darth vader used to be anakin skywalker
there was a grand moff tarkin tie-in book where
he suspects that darth vader might have once
been anakin skywalker who he fought with and knew
during the clone wars but most people believe that
anakin skywalker died when they went to mustafar
the emperor personally took him back and put him
in the armor so at the end of revenge of the sith
when he comes back in the armor in this scene here
like the tag scene at the end of the movie he
doesn't walk around telling everyone oh by the
way you remember me i used to be anakin skywalker
we fought together during the clone wars and it
sounds like if anybody did wind up finding out and
trying to use the name in close quarters or during
meetings darth vader or the emperor would probably
have them killed lego this person anakin skywalker
died a long time ago his wife died his children
died and he didn't have any known living relatives
because it also was not common knowledge that his
mother had been remarried to the lars family and
owen lars was kind of like his stepbrother in a
lot of the big revelations about luke skywalker
leia still being alive being darth vader's
children that stuff didn't happen until much
much later in the timeline ewan mcgregor also
did confirm that the series crosses over with the
timeline of the jedi following order of game but
i'm not expecting any big cal kestus cameo scenes
in live action or anything like that there might
be some easter eggs to the events of the games
but when it comes to stuff like that anything is
fair game like they brought dash rendar ship back
during rise of skywalker they even made revan
cannon during rise of skywalker so darth revan
is now canon to live-action star wars i think the
whole idea with darth vader and the inquisitors
not going after grosgu is because they probably
thought that he died during order 66 and whoever
saved him like the jedi librarian or whoever it
wound up being wound up being able to mask the
identities or hide part of the identities of the
people who survived not everybody but some people
a little while after order 66 had gone down the
jedi librarian jokostinu actually did survive
and she snuck back into the jedi temple and stole
a holocron that had all the identities of a bunch
of force sensitives until darth vader and the
grand inquisitor found her but the funny thing
is that darth vader actually got to her first
and killed her but not until he destroyed the
jedi holocron with the identities of all
these four sensitive people in the galaxy
and this is a recurring theme the reason why he
destroyed the knowledge of where all these force
sensitives were because the emperor did want to
find them and try to turn them to the dark side
and add them to the inquisitor's forces is like i
said earlier darth vader didn't want the emperor
finding more force sensitives because potentially
there was another person out there that was
powerful enough like grogu for instance who the
emperor could potentially train to replace him
so sort of like darth vader trying to do the smart
thing playing the long game because he never fully
trusted the emperor and he was right to do so for
those of you asking if there's supposed to be any
kind of emperor cameos during the series i'm not
expecting full-blown emperor but i do think that
he's going to be referenced during the series my
full episode 1 and episode 2 videos will post on
friday just like normal after they've released
them but there might be a bunch of big trailers
for like the mandalorian season 3 for andor maybe
for some of the other stuff maybe like an ahsoka
teaser trailer whatever they wind up releasing
in the next week of course i'll do videos for
it so be sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss that everyone click here for my
brand new thor love and thunder trailer video and
click here for all my other obi-wan kenobi trailer
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!